what's going on guys this is rob and we
are we're here we're at the conclusion
of dan slot spider-man run yes this run
that we've been covering for years
here on comics explained kind of off and
on infrequently but the whole run will
basically be done so we'll probably
combine this whole thing into a full
story and i don't even want to know how
long that video is going to be man it's
probably going to be longer than like
eight hours right i mean it's just gonna
be a colossal video but having said that
what this does is it initially picks up
with norman osborne basically in this
old room right this whole kind of home
for himself right the old osborne
residence and just talking to somebody
that we can't really see right now
following that what you actually end up
doing is picking up four hours
beforehand in the apartment of mary jane
watson where peter parker and mary jane
are making out now this is something dan
slott's kind of been a dick about over
the course of his run one of the big
things that spider-man fans hated we've
talked about this before and it's like
the one thing spider-man fans can just
never get past is the dissolution of
mary jane watson and spider-man their
whole relationship their whole marriage
and everything coming in the aftermath
or as part of spider-man one more day
and something that we're gonna do once
we get closer to the release of the
movie we're gonna remaster one more day
and then we're gonna cover brand new day
and then one moment in time right we're
gonna kind of do that trilogy of a story
one of the most reviled trilogies in the
history of the spider-man mythos
and we're gonna cover it but one of the
things that dan slott had constantly
done was tease this idea that maybe
spider-man and mary jane watson would
get back together but they never really
did and in fact this is the closest that
we ever really got where they were kind
of in a relationship but ultimately it
gets shut down and the reason why is
because from mary jane watson's
perspective kind of recalling her
history and the whole idea with peter
parker and spider-man all that kind of
stuff that it's one of these things
where she says like at the end of the
day the world needs spider-man more than
i need you right or more than you need
me and i can't have both i can't have
you all to myself because you have to be
spider-man you're going to put your life
in danger there are times when i'm going
to be worried about you there are times
when i'm going to be in danger because
of the fact that villains are going to
find out that you and i are together and
so because of all those things
ultimately she just kind of ends up
shooting the idea down and i wouldn't go
as far as to say peter parker's you know
a fan of it but i will go as far as to
say that peter parker is kind of like i
guess he understands it right and so
sort of goes forward and does his own
thing and so following that what you
actually end up getting here is again
kind of switching back to norman osborne
this whole thing where as he's talking
and as he's kind of going on the whole
drive of norman osborne has been to
figure out who spider-man is now one
thing i want to point out and something
that we covered in our video on norman
osborne the green goblin explained is
that norman osborne did at one point
know that peter parker was spider-man
ultimately marvel undid that because in
truth they just kind of found it to be
more reasonable to believe that norman
osborne didn't know that spider-man was
peter parker and indeed it actually made
for more compelling stories because with
something like that once an identity of
a superhero is known to a villain and
the whole shtick of that superhero is
that no one's supposed to know who his
identity is the most logical course of
action is for that villain to attack
that superhero's personal family and you
can only tell that story so many times
before people get tired of it and so
instead of making that a main caveat to
the spider-man mythos marvel just mixed
it and was just like nope we're not
playing that game at all right so
ultimately just kind of went away and so
at the moment norman osborne does not
know that peter parker is spider-man but
he's trying to figure it out and he's
been tracing off all these roots right
like horizon labs and max model where
peter parker served as part of that
think tank for a while that you had liz
allen who is uh who was at one point the
wife of harry osborne and basically the
mother of normie osborne that she
basically merged what was horizon labs
her own company and oscorp into what we
now call alcomax right she's a supremely
important and intelligent person but
trying to like trace all these roots and
trying to figure out what in the world
is going on here now of course there is
a point in time when phil urich the son
of benjaric the really more interesting
reporter not a super interesting plot
point here but basically the guy who's
the current iteration of the hobgoblin
really the hobgoblin king ultimately is
defeated by norman osborne right it was
kind of a cool little thing like
yes you know whatever norman osborne
versus the goblin king doesn't really
matter all that much norman osborne
defeats him kind of calls it a day but
then after that it's back to business
and as he goes through and kind of
continues talking to this unnamed person
that what you end up having is him
basically taking back his uh his green
goblin uniform now as we know the goblin
formula in the bloodstream of norman
osborn had been removed and it has been
for quite some time that was done by
peter parker so norman osborne being
able to actually transform into the
green goblin is gone but if you guys
remember the previous story that we did
the whole thing was that norman osborne
had basically bonded himself to the to
the carnage symbiote and then had used
that as kind of a backdoor method of
regaining the ability to turn into some
variation of the green goblin but as
he's doing this this person talking to
him basically says like he'll never be
able to defeat spider-man right like he
says like i do know who spider-man is
you're never going to beat him right
you're never going you're never going to
be able to defeat this guy the green
goblin's a loser you always have you
always will be you've done everything
you could to defeat this guy you even
threw his girl off a bridge and that's
when it clicks that's when norman
osborne's like wait a minute i threw his
girl off oh my god spider-man is peter
parker and that's that's like when he
finally figures it out and then you end
up finding out this unnamed person he's
talking to is jay jonah jameson that jay
jonah jameson inadvertently spilled the
beans that peter parker is spider-man
and so following that you pick back up
with the daily bugle now peter parker
had been rehired at the daily bugle
right kind of a way for dan's slot to
sort of bring things back to the way
they were when he initially started his
run and even before he started his run
right it's just one of those things
where the more things change the more
they stay the same and so while you have
peter parker kind of doing his thing and
talking to everybody and sort of heading
like the science division of of uh of
the daily bugle and all that kind of
stuff suddenly wow in comes the green
goblin right just smashes into this
place and just starts ripping everything
up and then tells peter parker knowing
he's spider-man get spider-man here in
60 seconds or less or i'm gonna kill
everybody right and so at that point you
peter parker does the only thing he can
do which is quote unquote he goes and he
gets spider-man right he goes and grabs
spider-man and brings it back now all
that's going on jay jonah jameson and
it's kind of going to be a little bit of
a background plot here it's basically
struggling with the idea that he is the
one that spilled the beans on
spider-man's true identity right so
basically everything that happens from
this point going forward j jonah jameson
takes as basically being his fault and
that was really more dan slott's kind of
testament to the character evolution of
j jonah jameson which had been going on
for quite some time even before dan slot
took over as writer but the idea of of
jay jonah jameson moving away from just
being this guy who ran the daily bugle
was basically always a dick to peter
parker ultimately ended up firing him
things like that he was always just kind
of a huge jerk a lot of that changed and
one of the things that you saw was that
he became a little more tender to peter
parker and even to spider-man a little
more lenient less just kind of like this
guy's a menace and he sucks and i hate
him and we're just gonna publish really
crappy things about him right that he
actually gained a lot of respect for
spider-man a lot of that was predicated
on the kind of things that spider-man
done even going so far as to save jonah
jameson's life on multiple occasions and
so because of that of course this kind
of fight breaks out between spider-man
and the green goblin but then you also
end up having flash thompson his agent
anti-venom who's a part of this as well
now his involvement here is largely due
to the fact that the hobgoblin had
stolen technology that belonged to
alcamax and so tracing down the
hobgoblin inevitably led him to where
the hobgoblin was defeated by norman
osborne which leads him to where jay
jonah jameson is which of course he ends
up freeing jay jonah jameson and so
that's when things kind of get a little
bit crazy it's because what you end up
having is switching over to harry osborn
one of his guys comes running in and
says look like norman osborne's back in
town right your dad's back as soon as
that happens their nanny basically
snatches the kids up and then
tranquilizes everybody and then leaves
right but the initial fight between
spider-man and green goblin is exactly
what you would expect right there is a
point where green goblin uses like some
technology of of uh phil urich to
basically try to blow the whole place up
and ultimately you know spider-man
basically ends up saving everybody from
the explosion there's a bunch of debris
right so people are injured but nobody's
killed which is really the main the main
goal here and then peter parker
confronts green goblin when he basically
seems to be impaled on a giant piece of
this building the crazy thing is that
peter parker does what peter parker
always does which is man i wish there
was a way to save you always kind of
being the good guy that sort of thing
and that's when norman osborne reveals
that he's actually bonded to the carnage
symbiote now this is cool and i gotta
say like at the time that this came out
even though we didn't really cover it it
was amazing like the idea of like the
green goblin becoming carnage was nuts
and it was one of those things it had
never occurred to me before right like
the idea of the green goblin taking the
carnage symbiote and bonding it to
himself one because the green goblin was
largely believed to have just been a
thing of the past right it made sense
norman osborne hadn't been relevant in
years there were other more compelling
villains and even just general
characters in the spider-man mythos that
have been written by dan slot so by all
standards of measurement if norman
osborne as the green goblin never came
back you probably wouldn't miss him
because there was just so much going on
in dan slot's run he didn't really spare
a second thought for the fact that
norman osborne was gone but having
osborne return and then like he has the
carnage symbiote he's literally firing
off what would normally be pumpkin bombs
but they're like carnage bombs that
actually physically latch onto things as
opposed to just landing in the general
vicinity and exploding it's awesome
right it's one of the cool things now
the other part about this and i love the
way the dance slot played this peter
parker realizes right off the bat he's
no match for this right he's no match
for the red goblin right and immediately
just kind of like i gotta go right like
like it's kind of like i gotta run i
gotta flee i gotta do something i gotta
grab my bearings that's why he basically
stays in hiding right because within the
span of about 30 seconds the red goblin
overpowered spider-man to the point that
like he's basically in shambles right
like his legs ripped to pieces with that
that bomb blew up on him and all that
kind of stuff and that's when he tells
him i don't ever want to see you
operating a spider-man again right like
if i see a web if i see anything that
indicates that you are spider-man i'm
gonna kill everybody you know because i
know who you are and there's nowhere you
can take them there's nowhere you can
put them where i won't be able to find
them and that makes sense remember the
resources of norman osborne as he's been
bidding his return have expanded greatly
that's one of the reasons why dan sloth
gave us those stories where norman
osborne had contacts in like asia and
south africa and was part of like these
great big huge you know underground
movements that were looking to
consolidate power in different ways he
was kind of an information broker by
operating on a global scale it allowed
norman osborne to gain global contacts
and peter parker realizes this he
realizes that when norman osborne says i
will find you no matter where you go in
the world it's not a bluff that he
actually will be able to using his
contacts and he'll kill everybody that
peter parker cares about and so that's
when peter parker kind of says okay fine
deal right and he makes a deal and just
leaves the role of being spider-man
seemingly forever of course as we know
until ultimately norman osborne is
defeated and so in his stead what he
does here is really genius and i love
the way that norman osborne played this
what you end up getting is basically a
kind of coming together of the superhero
community who are basically keeping an
eye on the various members of
spider-man's family but it's largely
just people spider-man knows and is
intimately familiar with i don't mean
just like you know like they're kissing
and stuff like that i mean like
intimately familiar with in the sense
that like they're exceedingly close
right so like miles morales you have
silk right silk of course being one of
the characters that was created as part
of like the the end of the spite of her
storyline somebody that has kind of will
she she has an intimate relationship
with peter parker they were banging like
rabbits when she first showed up right
you guys remember that they couldn't
stop banging man like it was crazy it
was it was hilarious flash thompson
agent anti-venomous here of course he
ended up rescuing uh j-jonah jameson but
it's also kind of a few cool things that
you see going on because ultimately jay
jonah jameson actually contacts peter
parker and peter parker just kind of
like he knows my identity right and the
response to jameson is yes i know i
inadvertently told him he had me tied up
and i basically said that he threw your
girlfriend uh you know gwen stacy off
the bridge and that's when he realized
what was going on at that moment peter
parker hangs up now one thing to know
it's not as though peter parker
absolutely despises jay jonah jameson
because of this he does recognize the
nature of nuance right that sometimes
people just end up letting things slip
the difference here though is that he
expected better of j jonah jameson right
he expected that if that if his identity
was going to be elite it wouldn't come
from somebody like j jonah jameson being
sloppy spouting off of the mouth and
revealing the wrong kind of information
and so following that you actually end
up picking up with the nanny of liz
allen and harry osborne's kids of course
snatching them up and is basically on
the run ultimately she's caught up to by
liz allen of course when you're the head
of alcomax right one like one of the
single biggest corporations in the world
you're gonna be found like you're gonna
be able to find people right it's just
that's just the way that it is and then
of course the red goblin shows up and
attacks them all and that's when you end
up finding out here that the nanny of of
harry osborne and liz allen's kids is
actually norman osborne's at least
believed to have been long dead wife
right harry osborne's mom it's a crazy
thing she was believed to have been dead
for a long
long long time in fact that was the
major focal point behind the
relationship between harry and norman in
the early days of marvel comics or at
least the early days of norman osborne's
appearances right that he constantly
pushed his son that in a lot of ways he
kind of abandoned being a true father
figure in terms of being like
emotionally supportive of his son and
instead just gave him things and so it's
one of those things where not really
having a nurturing hand in his life in a
lot of ways is what led harry osborn to
one resent his father and two to fall
down the path of actually becoming the
green goblin himself after norman
osborne was seemingly killed the idea
was that because norman osborne was just
so dark and so sadistic because he was
so twisted that she actually faked her
death and it kind of snuck her way back
ever since and it sort of makes sense
right this was one of those things that
was met with kind of a mixed reaction by
comic fans but he could you know she
couldn't just show up right and just be
like harry i'm your mom can i watch your
kids you know i mean i want to be a mom
again
you would expect the kind of visceral
reaction that most any of us would have
which is where have you been all this
time why would i trust you right i mean
having her kind of sneak her way back in
sort of snake her way back in and then
having the revelation sort of coming out
in this same capacity it's pretty
shocking the most disappointing thing
about this is that this comes at the
very end of danslot's run you're not
gonna see much coming out of this it's
one of these things a dance slot
developed presumably with the intention
of possibly building on it later in the
sense of somebody else using that but
ultimately it didn't become like a major
focal point it kind of did but not
really and so one of the things that
happens here is you actually end up
having all these different members of
kind of spider-man's inner circle who
all basically arrive here with the
intention of facing off against the red
goblin and defeating him and all of them
are defeated right every single one of
them including flash thompson agent
anti-venom right the red goblin
overpowers them all and almost he almost
goes in to kill flash thompson but then
ultimately lets him leave and so
following that he ends up actually
snatching up normie osborne right
basically his grandson and then
basically turning him into what is in
effect a carnage goblin right kind of
turning him into a facsimile of himself
and the two of them sort of go forward
from there now the motivation behind
that is thin at best right that's one of
the things that was really disappointing
about this is that what you end up
learning here is the goal of norman
osborne as the carnage symbiote is to
basically retake his empire and i
understand where dan slot was coming
from because the whole motivation of
norman osborn in the early days of his
appearances was to basically acquire a
huge amount of wealth and and influence
right to basically live at kind of the
top of the criminal underworld and even
in this instance it kind of the top of
the corporate world and then just kind
of control everything from there the
reality of this though is we're long
since past such simple plot points when
it comes to villains and heroes and
things like that it's interesting to see
but people in this day and age when they
read comics kind of want a little bit
more right the idea of like a villain
doing what they do because they just
want to acquire wealth or power that's
something that you normally see with
like a b-list villain that's not really
something that you expect from norman
osborn even if that was the basis behind
his character in the early days the
biggest issue that you have here is what
would be the role of norman osborne in
this era and so that's one of the
reasons why dan slott largely seems to
have gone with that whole decision now
of course peter parker ends up kind of
staying behind and basically helping
like miles morales and and cindy moon
and and flash thompson and all these
guys right johnny storm of the fantastic
four of course one of his personal
friends helping them all out and that's
when you also get a little revelation
here in the sense that like traditional
powers as they're normally used against
symbiotes right fire and sound they
don't work not in the same capacity that
they normally do right if this was
cletus cassidy as carnage any one of
those things would work right you'd be
able to blast him with sonics you'd be
able to set him on fire and you could
overpower the symbiote and then actually
try to push it back into cletus cassidy
right because the cardist symbiote can't
really be removed from cletus since his
bond to his bloodstream but here with
the red goblet it doesn't work that way
he's basically immune to most any
weakness that symbiotes normally have
now one of the things you actually get
here and is kind of a genius moment from
j jonah jameson is he sits down in his
apartment he's like okay so like
obviously norman osborne's running
around as a green goblin with a carnage
symbiote okay what symbiote out there
could defeat carnage and that's when it
dawns on him okay so it's definitely
gotta be venom but like how do i find
eddie brock like i mean eddie brock
isn't a guy that you just you call up
right i mean he doesn't really work that
way but then it turns out he is and the
reason why
in one of the funniest things ever the
reason why is because eddie brock is
basically running the same scam that
spider-man ran where peter parker would
take pictures of himself as spider-man
and then sell them to the daily bugle
basically eddie brock's doing the same
thing with venom
it's pretty amazing when you think about
it like it's not the worst idea right
not the worst idea at all i mean it
worked for peter parker stands to reason
it would work for eddie brock and it
does right it actually does in fact he
works at a at a newspaper called the
fact sheet
it's kind of uh you know nowhere near as
big as the daily bugle but he's still
basically doing the same thing not only
that eddie brock is calling himself mr
sim right so obviously eddie brock is
one of the least imaginative people you
could ever imagine and honestly it's
always kind of been that way
even now i mean i love eddie brock don't
get me wrong i love eddie brock
absolutely love eddie brock but he's
never really had any imagination
and so what ends up happening here is
that j jonathan jameson actually gets a
hold of eddie brock and says hey man
like the carnage symbiote has bonded
itself to the green goblin or at least
norman osborne welcomed the transition
and now like things are popping off we
need you to help and what ends up
actually happening here is you switch
over to stark tower where mary jane
watson's kind of doing her thing and you
actually end up having the the venom
symbiote kind of going after her not
really intentionally it's more to gain
information and so what you end up
getting here is basically this kind of
fight between the red goblin and venom
and this is cool man like it's one of
the cool things right this story was
really kind of the swan song of dan's
slime right like hey guys have you ever
wanted to see what would happen if like
the carnage symbiote bonded itself to
the green goblin and then fought like
venom and miles morales and spider-man
and like everybody else in the
spider-man mythos well you can see it
right now right that was basically his
whole thing
and it was cool right it was awesome of
course as you would expect norman
osborne overpowers venom and it actually
leads to spider-man and venom teaming up
to face off against the red goblin but
again while they are able to hold their
own to a degree at the end of the day
the power of the red goblin is just too
much he's far more powerful than either
green goblin or carnage by themselves
and is able to overpower both now the
funny thing about this is this has huge
callbacks to maximum carnage right it's
got massive callbacks to maximum cars i
know a lot of you guys are pretty og we
covered maximum carnage but like do you
guys remember what it was like reading
that story when it came out it was
amazing
watching karna's just like wreck venom
and spider-man at the same time it was
pretty cool but on top of that what you
end up realizing here is that ultimately
eddie brock and spider-man teaming up it
just kind of won't work it's actually
eddie brock who realizes that right
where he's like you and i teaming up
together it's just not gonna work right
i mean this guy is not carnage he's not
cletus cassidy he's not the guy that
we're familiar with we need to basically
be greater than the sum of their parts
and so what he actually ends up doing is
giving his venom symbiote back to peter
parker and peter parker goes back to
being venom again
which i absolutely loved right j
jonathan jameson digs out one of his old
spider slayers right and then basically
uses like the ability to remote control
it to try to send it out and take out
the red goblin which of course doesn't
work right i mean like he literally just
gets crushed i mean it's not even not
even close i mean nobody ever expected
that to succeed it's kind of the funny
thing jonah jameson's trying his best
right i mean he can't help but feel bad
for the guy right i mean he's doing his
best he's doing what he can he can't do
much but the fact that he's even trying
i think speaks volumes to the evolution
of jay jonah jameson but peter parker in
possession of the venom symbiote and
then facing off against against red
goblin is really really cool here
because it kind of turns into a bit of a
cat and mouse game right peter parker's
standard powers are basically augmented
given the venom semi right increased
strength increased speed increased
agility so it makes him much much closer
to the red goblin and in fact it seems
as though he gains the upper hand and so
one of the things that red goblin does
here is he says when i attacked
everybody that you knew right like
you're on may when i attacked cindy moon
when i attacked all these different
people what i did is i basically planted
in them these little barbs and these
little barbs will basically give me
control over them right so this is kind
of the early stages or really sort of
the early indications of where it is
that donnie kate's at least began to
develop the idea of carnage basically
taking over people in their entirety
this had happened before that's
something that i do want to point out
here it's not the first time we ever saw
carnage basically taking over people but
it is cool to see it happen in this way
when it's the personal family members of
peter parker and so peter parker
actually ends up deviating off course uh
basically stops following red goblin of
course with the intention of basically
trying to save as his various family
members and that's when you end up uh
having flash thompson who basically
reveals as ancient anti-venom that's
what i was doing when i was running
around to each of these individual
people i was removing the barbs from
them right like i'm agent antiven i'm
like i literally cure symbiotes that's
kind of my thing right like i cure
impurities that sort of thing and so
ultimately the two of them actually team
up to face off against red goblin and
the reason why here is because if
spider-man wants to stand the best
possible chance of defeating the red
goblin he's gonna need like flash
thompson to pull this off right he's
gonna need this guy to do it he's gonna
he's gonna absolutely need flash
thompson an agent anti-venom and that's
kind of the funny thing right peter
parker teaming up with his high school
bully to defeat norman osborne kind of
crazy the funny thing about this though
and what makes this wild is that because
of the fact that norman osborne has this
green goblin tech in addition to a
symbiote and because of the fact that as
the red goblin he's immune to the normal
weaknesses of a symbiote that means
things like electricity fire all that
kind of stuff he can use right and so
actually what he ends up doing is
attacking flash thompson and basically
just shocking the absolute life out of
this guy and basically electrocutes him
to the point where he basically kills
flash thompson now when that happens the
death of flash thompson here this was
nuts right it's one of those this is one
of the things that made this story so
crazy is because it's like oh my god the
red goblin just killed flash tantra
right he just killed agent ante even
this is where agent ante venom died and
it's one of the things that we talked
about during the events of king and
black where flash thompson came back
right where he ended up returning during
that event that's one of the things that
made it so cool because remember guys
people loved flash thompson as agent
venom and agent anti-venom people
thought it was just one of the coolest
developments for his character ever and
even to this day people talk about how
great that was and so having this whole
thing go down here peter parker lashes
out and when he does his symbiote begins
to gain the better of him of course he's
able to kind of retake himself kind of
regain his bearings he stops becoming
that kind of twisted sadistic version of
venom and just sort of goes back to
being peter parker in control of his own
symbiote suit but at this point now has
become a much more personal vendetta
because what this really establishes
here is that when you have red goblin
show up and some guy's dressed up as
spider-man it's like man why are you on
my spot right like you got to go work
out go work in some other spot that he
kills this guy right and that's what
peter parker kind of realizes this guy
has no remorse whatsoever now the crazy
thing is peter already kind of knew this
right i mean it's the hearted symbiote
which already loves inflicting as much
harm as it possibly can combined with
the sociopathic nature of norman osborn
i mean it was a recipe for just as much
destruction as you could possibly
imagine and so because of the fact that
peter parker doesn't you know seems to
be in on this idea that if they keep
fighting in their normal forms more
people will die what he actually ends up
doing is manipulating norman osborn and
saying look like i mean we can keep on
fighting like this and sure you'll
overpower me and you'll kill me but
here's the problem man everybody's gonna
say it's because of carnage you never
beat me because it was actually you
nobody will ever say green goblin
defeated spider-man nobody will ever say
green goblin killed spider-man what
they'll say is carnage defeated
spider-man is that really what you want
do you really want your carnage symbiote
to be the one that gets all the credit
for this crazy deed that you managed to
pull off that cletus cassidy is the one
who killed spider-man and that's what
kind of drives norman osborne to
basically seize control of himself and
actually cast the symbiote off more so
than that spider-man does the exact same
thing now this was cool right and we
kind of knew it was going in this
direction it's the classic fight
spider-man versus the green goblin now
this is kind of a follow-up to the fight
that we saw before but the fight that we
saw before was spider-man versus just
norman osborne having spider-man fight
the green goblin here there is so much
history and so much rage and anger that
goes into this fight right because
remember guys green goblin is kind of
the amalgamation of everything that
represents spider-man losing things that
are important to him right in this fight
he talks about how uncle ben had died
and the death of uncle ben basically
taught him about what it meant to be
courageous it meant that if you have the
power to do something you have the
responsibility to do that thing he talks
about the nature of sacrifice and he
talks about life by the idea that norman
osborne had taken gwen stacy away from
spider-man right and that's one of the
most important things we've mentioned
that before right the death of uncle ben
taught spider-man that if he can act he
has the responsibility to act but the
death of gwen stacy i would say was more
important than the death of uncle ben
because it taught spider-man he can't be
reckless that he has to be careful with
the power that he has it's one thing to
be a superhero and to just be a heroic
person who does heroic things but you
have to understand nuance you have to
understand what it means to be a hero in
relation to those who are weaker than
you and how to handle those kinds of
things not only that he reflects on
friends he reflects on family he
reflects on the fact that this fight he
has with the green goblin and
overpowering and defeating green goblin
is not just peter parker fighting for
himself it's peter parker fighting for
everyone he cares about for everybody
who's important to him both people who
were dead and people who were alive that
he's surrounded by people who in one
form or another have improved and shaped
his life in a way that have made him
better and so as a result of that when
he overpowers the green goblin that the
green goblin calls out for the carnage
symbiote and that's when it dawns on
peter parker the carnage symbiote is
just it's a symbiote now it's just by
itself it's not bonded to the goblin
formula so it has all the weaknesses of
the symbiote normally has he's like okay
i need fire where can i find fire and he
looks around he's like i can find fire
everywhere
everything's on fire somebody just
starts grabbing things and just
snatching like just smashing him into
the symbiote and basically trying to
destroy the karna symbiote which he
seemingly successfully does not only
that one of the crazy things that
happens here is that as that's going on
with spider-man you have j-jonah jamison
who comes out of nowhere with a handgun
with the intention of shooting norman
osborn now this is a massive moment and
the reason why is because as we've done
so many times before on this channel
this breaks down into a philosophical
discussion is spider-man really doing
anybody any good by keeping norman
osborn alive and handing him over to the
police right one of the things he says
as he approaches norman osborne is he
says osborne you're not fooling me with
that act you're not fooling anybody this
has to stop and when spider-man
approaches him and says like what are
you doing you got to put the gun down
the response to jameson is i'm not
stupid parker i know how this works
he'll be back and he knows he'll take
someone else betty robbie your aunt my
son me no this is my fault i have to end
it right kind of the culmination of this
feeling that he's been experiencing that
he's the reason why norman osmond was
able to achieve all this in the first
place by figuring out the identity of
spider-man now one of the things here
and this is something to notice j-john
and jameson doesn't really hesitate here
it's not one of these things where he
shows kind of a moment of uncertainty
right he's just like this is my fault i
have to end it bow right goes to pull
the trigger now spider-man jumps in
front of it and actually saves the life
of norman osborne this in turn is a
reflection of what peter parker truly
stands for and even james j john
jamieson asked that he's like why would
you do that in response to peter is
because i could and that meant that i
had to because with great power there
must also come great responsibility to
everyone even the worst of us and that's
kind of the crazy thing is because in
reality norman osborne kind of needed to
die now what ends up happening here with
norman osborne's life being saved you
get this crazy scenario right the guy's
basically locked up in ravencroft asylum
right just sort of locked away but one
of the things that happens here is peter
parker as spider-man goes to visit
norman osborne and this was really more
of just kind of checking up and seeing
has he spilled the beans on who i am has
he told anybody who i am the real
question you have to ask here is he's in
an asylum even if he did would anybody
actually believe him but he asked him he
was like okay like how are we to play
this right you know my identity you know
what's going on how are we going to play
this and ultimately he's just kind of
like i know who you are right you're the
world's biggest screw-up that kind of a
thing he's like you're norman osborne
and peter's like what okay so so who are
you again and that's when norman osborne
responds i'm cletus cassidy and so in
essence the personality really the kind
of the the mental imprint of cletus
cassidy seems to have just basically
bonded itself to norman osborne in
effect by norman osborne having the
goblin formula and then also combining
that with the the carnage symbiote it
basically made him insane he's
completely and totally lost his mind
right now this was basically the idea of
of uh dan slott kind of writing it out
right and saying okay so like this is
where the green goblin stands now right
green goblin is absolutely insane it's
sort of closing closing off this loop
but also leaving a bit of a way out in
case somebody wants to bring norman
osborne back it's pretty easy to cure
somebody of insanity in marvel comics so
it could kind of go either way either he
stays in ravencroft asylum and as far as
we're aware and in terms of marvel
publishing we don't see him for 20 years
or it could be that nick spencer brings
him back in like 10 issues and he's
cured of his insanity and just kind of
goes about and does his normal thing
returns as quote unquote the green
goblin the other thing about this is
that there is an effort to basically
remove the carnage symbiote from normie
and to a degree it seems to work that
the symbiote is basically siphoned off
of him and basically destroyed in the
process of course you end up learning
there are remnants of the symbiotes
still there right so that's kind of a
thing where it's a potential plot thread
that could be used at a future point in
time and then of course you pick up with
this idea of uh really this kind of
funeral for flash thompson where
everybody sort of says their goodbyes
and it's one of the things that peter
kind of mutes on he actually gives us
really really amazing speech right given
the history the fact that flash thompson
ridiculed and bullied peter parker so
often when they were in high school he
says hey flash man always so cool this
guy he knew a waltz from a cha-cha who
am i kidding you were a bully you were
my bully when i think of all the lockers
that you shoved me into but here's this
thing right bullies don't come out of
nowhere someone always hurt them first
didn't find that out about you until
years later and then he says then one
day everything changed you told me that
you found a hero to look up to and you
started a life of service helped your
fellow man saved so many lives
protecting others in ways people will
never know you became a man that we're
all so proud of and me i found myself to
be a bit of a bully now and then making
fun of others rattling their cages
telling myself they deserved it and he
says i want you to know that i want to
change because of you flash thompson i
hope you can be proud of me i know
you're my friend but there's something i
never told you i'm your number one fan
you're the hero that i look up to and
that's a huge statement coming from
peter parker given the kind of history
they have together but following that
right you know i mean you basically have
business as usual right things pop off
peter parker races off he's like i gotta
go be spider-man you know and you know
you have j jones jamison he's like
parker you know that kind of a thing and
then it's back to spider-man being
spider-man oh that being said guys this
is the end we're completely done with
dan slot spider-man run let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section we are going to make a full
story video out of all of this because
it's just been one crazy and fun
adventure but we finally finished it
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace
you